a league known for speed NASCAR gaint
action this year as they announce you
get that traction is old pun that so
it's wonderful wonderful
so they announced a four hundred million
dollar renovation of the Daytona
International Speedway joining us for
more is Brian France France he is
NASCAR's CEO and chairman and more
important he's up for a big award
tonight executive the world for the SBJ
right we are and good luck with that
Brian well we'll see what happens they
were excited so let's start with this
Daytona renovation it's four hundred
million dollars tell us what you did you
actually took some capacity out of the
stadium didn't you took some capacity
out it's the only stadium like
Motorsports facility in the world so it
looks and feels like you would be at a
football game or in arena all the
amenities the seating the club seating
mezzanine Suites and all the rest and
they did a great job with it so the few
reduced capacity that must mean that you
increased the cost of a ticket reprice
some things that's true and you know you
know higher value more premium seating
more premium offerings so a better
experience and obviously the revenue has
to be there
to match that it's all private capital
so has to be returned and there is a
return so in other words has the
response been actually good it's been
great we sold out the early feedback
from the fan base is great they love it
and this has never been done before
motorsports and you know we're one of
the few that puts all private capital up
not too much in the private partner ship
arena for us in a NASCAR so we're real
proud of how it turned out Brian not
everyone in our audience may understand
really the NASCAR business as a business
it's a family owned business and it's
not publicly traded so but give us a
little bit insight I mean one of the
statistics I saw was nearly a hundred
nearly half of the hundred fortune top
companies advertise with NASCAR where do
you get your revenues from to break it
out for us how much was from ticket
sales so much from from television
advertising other well media is the
largest you know a source of income for
for us and for any any league actually
but tickets but corporate sponsorship
and commercial involvement means more to
us than anybody else and
we have more involvement in that regard
we have more companies more fortune 50
more fortune 500 companies because they
get to own something in NASCAR they're
not a billboard in the stadium they're
not sort of buying media within the
broadcast they're actually you know
helping us you know run the events it's
their team on the playing field or on
the racetrack rather and it works out
great for us Ron the question I would
ask is your growth potential is it
restricted to the borders of the United
States
no and North Americans are most
competitive right but but auto racing
has played all around the world one of
the few soccer being the other example
of that and so we have some
opportunities from to put our style in
our brand but it's tricky because road
racing and Formula one obviously around
the world is the most popular so our
brand is tight oval racing you know
we're gonna we're gonna have some
contact out there and maybe a little bit
for a middle one Mason trying to make a
push in this country still Matt Miller
not with us he's offering Berlin my
colleague but the question I asked him
was Houston f1 end of the year can we
get tickets we said easy we'll get
tickets no problem because it's still
not huge in this country do you worry
about the challenge coming from Formula
well since it dominates globally they
can only run a couple of events at most
so to get any frequency of events in
this country it's hard for that it's
hard for anybody so we're running every
weekend and our style is this oval track
you know closer than you park your car
you know they're they're mixing it up
and that's very different than Formula
one where there's something else going
on how much has the viewership and fan
base increased over the past few years
well you know we you know we've
increased in some regards our social
media and all the rest has done credit
we're blowing it up and in all those
metrics we're still one or two coming in
and out of the weekend on cable with our
with Fox and NBC as our partners so
we've done really well you know however
you want to measure it but I always tell
people this is the most competitive
market place in the world for sports we
don't think of it that way but
culturally when you put all the
collegiate that's here and you put all
the professional leagues they're all
well managed they're all well entrenched
so that
do as well as we do every weekend is a
is a testament this is a tough
marketplace